one of the things I found really helpful
was to write a creative breakup letter
you know to the recruitment industry and
it would be like you know I hate how you
treat your staff I hate how you kind of
write fake jobs I hate how you do all
these things that traditional bad
recruitment companies do if you're going
to launch a recruitment company you know
spoiler alert the world doesn't need
another recruitment company probably in
your sector whatever it is even if it's
AI what they do need is a company that
is different to the rest for a good
reason and more I wrote that thing the
more I started to figure out oh there's
some Trends in here that you could build
a proposition around this right and you
can hire accordingly we the people that
we're not the people that I knew if I
hired like that and I designed our
business like that the end goal would be
better